I'm willing to bet most of you are
eagerly awaiting Kingdom Hearts 3 or the
Final Fantasy 7 remake or both and
they're still gonna be a while I'm Tony
and this is your far-off GameSpot news
update
a recent Square Enix investors document
lays out some of the company's biggest
upcoming releases Kingdom Hearts final
fantasy and even the company's upcoming
Marvel projects have no release window
for this year by comparison the final
fantasy 12 remake has its exact release
date listed and Dragon Quest 11 at least
has a vague 2017 stamp while it's not
the most reassuring document none of
those future release windows have been
formally announced so hit that subscribe
button and you'll be the first to know
if something changes for what it's worth
Square Enix's Avengers project with
Marvel was only revealed at the
beginning of this year and the company
said we wouldn't even hear more until
2018 but hey if you want more comic-book
action right now you can always swing by
our GameSpot Universe channel
[Music]
you